yeah so if your mom and dad went out to
dinner with you and you're sixteen years
old and your parents bought you the beer
with a meal you're alone yeah but also
who lives in Wisconsin I'm really good
people that I really want to listen I
mean yes was from there yes murderer
Jeffrey Dahmer summer good guiding yeah
he did most of his eating there tell me
another person that was able to put
people in walls what's his name H
William 8 no no will you mate you may
see this Klaus you're amazing dancing so
great I'm a fan of all these guys what's
great about him is the he wasn't their
originator of all those putting people
inside walls yeah where's mom where's
mom's living in the house yeah he did it
with family that's pretty that's [ __ ]
great that's crap come down for dinner
one second yeah but yeah what uh what
I'm wondering is that you don't smell it
lady like there's were 30 bodies you
know you notice it's like um it's like
Bates Motel
you know we're like they know what's
going on but it's like you just pretend
to know no do you ever have a friend in
high schools you guys have a friend in
high school or when you were young that
like they're like oh you can drink and
party at that house and the parents were
like fake oblivious yeah well [ __ ] they
knew they were know what's going on up
there it's like we're smoking pot
there's no way your mother smell pot
when I was in high school in Rancho
Bernardo there was a lady named Lucy
and she had like three babies but she
also had a meth lab that's where I got
my math and I used to go there and wait
for my math and I'd see babies just
crawling around the meth lab like it was
crazy that wasn't a moment of clarity
for you know that was I got my bottom
that was Lucy's bottom maybe baby babies
weren't it no no that is my babies yeah
who cares
yeah and she sold you she showed you
meth and then yeah baby
you get meth and a baby yeah you get
them out yeah like at the weed start to
give you a free joint you get yeah but
it's a thing with cute white babies I
remember - I felt bad about him who
what's the cutest race of baby black
babies you girls always say black baby
thing Asian right I do think a very
close second see black girls always say
black babies yeah I oh I've always
thought Asian babies the cutest and then
you know then they grow up what you
don't realize is that who look like a
baby that black babies girls always say
black babies yeah yeah cuz they are
they're pretty close just very we over
feed them when they're young really
round round be like a morality that's
why I love that but white babies are the
ugliest thing and 90% of white babies
are gross yeah because they're like
they're too like ghastly looking present
presidents to me yeah exactly not even
like cuz they're bald they're bald their
eyes are big yeah white babies are
present babies are never held a baby
except for c-section babies they always
come out looking perfect I hate it
yeah hate it but I'm just saying they're
perfect ask you about it it comes out
through the vaginal canal the heads all
deform and you know they look all just
such a baby big head though c-section
baby yeah but that's your beauty it's
deformed that's a race that's a Filipino
race they deformed it's just a momentary
like wow I'm not being racist but that's
just where you from the country of
origin oh you would know I mean I
would've felt sorry for your mother she
had to birth that head not - baby yeah
c-sections one of the babies had two
heads
I mean her vagina even normal no no
the tummy man oh that's why I met my dad
he doesn't know it that's what I don't
even know what C sexes section is where
they could put a hole in the tummy and
they pull it out that way why don't they
do it the other way because sometimes
the mom isn't able to birth normal no no
this is this conversation is happening
also with a parent and a six-year-old
now you can do a callback to have one
call thank you what call back